good morning believe nation today's
messages chase physical and mental
energy over to you Jerry Seinfeld
putting in a phenomenal day's work to me
is way better than you know let's say
you come into a little chunk of money
you didn't think you were gonna get you
know you just get some dough and you go
hey that's great that's that is great
I think money's great but energy
physical and mental energy to me is the
greatest riches of human life so listen
to what Jerry says about chasing energy
versus chasing the dollars and I think
it comes into play a lot for
entrepreneurs where for me it's the
thing about doing something practical
versus something that that you really
love doing something that will give you
a lot of energy and sometimes we'll do
the same thing sometimes a practical
thing to do is the thing that you love
doing and in that case it's an easy
decision often you go for but sometimes
they're at opposite ends where the
practical thing to do the easy thing the
same thing the smart thing the thing
everybody's telling you to do is not the
same thing is the thing that you really
want to do the thing that you're most
excited about doing and the risk for
entrepreneurs is going after that thing
that you love doing that might make you
come alive where you get such a high
from doing that's where you have to go
that's where the gold is gonna be in and
the long term money is gonna be but it
may not make the most short-term
practical sense for all of you watching
or entrepreneurs you know what I'm
talking about you know those inter that
you've had to make and having the
courage to jump into the unknown and
chase the thing that gives you energy
and makes you come alive can be scary
compared to doing the thing as practical
safe and easy to do ideally you want to
find the thing that you can get lost in
for me it's helping entrepreneurs and
I'm fortunate and blessed and really
grateful that I found that early on in
my life where I love helping
entrepreneurs and I can spend the whole
day helping entrepreneurs and I don't
lose energy I gain energy it makes me
come alive and makes
me so super happy even to my own
detriment where I'm neglecting my health
or neglecting doing bigger things
because I'm spending so much time and so
fully engaged in helping entrepreneurs
out that the time just passes and I
sincerely hope that you can find the
thing for you that makes you come alive
that you can just spend hours and the
time just passes and that can contribute
to other people and add value to their
lives in a significant way as well so
the question they today is I'm curious
what gives you energy in your business
leave it in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion I want to give a
quick shout out to the Savar from sleep
and Beyond sävar thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book it really
means a lot to me those are you guys
watching if you want your chance and I
shout out in a future video make sure to
buy a copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and they'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spresso